joining us now former acting department
of homeland security secretary during
the trump administration chad wolfe uh
thank you so much for joining us i mean
you watched that little girl to hear
that she
and her mother both perished there in
the arizona desert i mean it is human
trafficking it is real it's not just
numbers of people coming across these
are real human beings who are losing
their lives because they've been
incentivized to come to the united
states
well it's absolutely correct and that's
a heartbreaking story but we we see a
lot of those throughout the course of
the year and throughout this crisis
but we have to remember that the bite
administration
again is encouraging these individuals
we're seeing historic numbers month
after month after month and in the
process we see more migrant deaths in
the desert that public safety officials
and border patrol are seeing every day
but we're also seeing more in-custody
deaths in cbp and that's because of the
sheer number
of individuals crossing that border
illegally every month and so this border
policy that the biden administration has
uh partaken and undergone over the last
several months is a very inhumane uh
policy that's having some devastating
consequences
there were some 65 000 people that came
across as unaccompanied minors our
understanding is roughly a third of
those are unaccounted for the bite
administration has totally lost track
with them they thought they could just
get a telephone number and call and
check up on them but they can't find
them now i mean how is that not human
trafficking and how is it that we allow
so many unaccompanied minors just loose
within the united states of america
well we need to keep in mind that this
is the same administration that rolled
back trump era vetting requirements for
those same sponsors we had put in place
a very robust sponsoring uh procedures
to make sure we knew who those
individuals were that we were placing
these miners with this administration
rolled back those and now they are
releasing them they don't know where
they're at which makes it even more
difficult for these miners to show up to
their immigration proceedings which they
are required to do by law but if you
can't even locate them you can't locate
them or their sponsor then you know
they're not showing up for court and so
it's exactly right jason it's it's human
trafficking really at its worst
well and the other thing that's being
trafficked
are a lot of drugs i mean fentanyl is
reportedly more dangerous more deadly
than heroin and yet the bite
administration is actually looking to
following through on this idea that they
these crimes they would lessen the
penalties for them how is that going to
help
make our country more safe and secure
well it's not at the end of the day
i think folks need to keep in mind that
the historic number of folks that we are
seeing cross the border enrich the
cartels every day for every individual
crossing that border it's five to ten
thousand dollars that they pay a cartel
member
these cartels are putting that money
back into their illicit business they
continue to traffic illegal narcotics
such as fentanyl and others and the 200
percent that you mentioned at the top of
the segment is only in the amount that
we are
actually apprehending and we know that
the vast majority is getting through and
why do we know that because border
patrol agents are no longer on the line
doing their national security mission
they're back in facilities trying to
care for all these migrants that are
coming across that border so the 200
increase is a good start but it's only a
small percentage of actually what's
coming through that border again fueled
by the cartels and fueled by the byte
administration's policies
yeah the drug cartels know what they're
doing unfortunately and this
administration doesn't but hey you know
kamala harris she's on top of it i i
there should be nothing to worry about
um former acting department of homeland
security secretary chad wolfe thank you
for your service thanks for joining us
on sunday morning futures